let's get some practice simplifying
hairy expressions that have exponents in
them and so we have a hairy expression
right over here and I encourage you to
pause the video and see if you can
rewrite this in a in a simpler way all
right let's work through this together
and the first thing that jumps out at me
is the numerator here I have number 125
raised to the 1/8 power times the same
number the same base 125 raised to the
5/8 power so I can rewrite this
numerator I can rewrite this numerator
using what I know of exponent properties
as being equal to 125 to the sum of
these two exponents to the negative 1/8
power plus 5/8 power all of that is
going to be over the existing
denominator we have which is five to the
one-half all of that is going to be over
five to the one half power so these are
equivalent notice all I did is I added
the exponents these two exponents cuz I
had the same base and we were taking the
product of both of these both 125 to the
negative 1/8 and 125 to the 5/8 and so
negative 1/8 plus 5/8 well that is 1/2
so this is this right over here is 1/2
so this is 125 to the 1/2 over 5 to the
1/2 well that's going to be the same
thing this is going to be equivalent to
125 over 5 over 5 to the 1/2 power to
the 1/2 power if I raise 125 to the 1/2
and I'm dividing by 5 to the 1/2 that's
the same thing as doing the division
first and then raising that to the 1/2
power
well what's 125 divided by 5 well that's
just 25 and what's 25 to the 1/2 well
that's the same thing as the principal
square root of 25 which is equal to 5
and we're all done that's simplified
quite nicely let's do another one of
these and this one is a little more
interesting because we are starting to
involve a variable we have the variable
W but it's really going to be somewhat
the same the same process and here the
thing that jumps out at me is
is the denominator I have the same base
3w squared 3w squared raised to one
power one exponent times the same base
3w squared raised to another power so
this is going to be equal to this is
going to be equal to our numerator we
can just rewrite it 12 w to the seventh
power over negative three halves over
our denominator we can write as this
base 3w squared 3 w squared and we can
add these two exponents so we could add
negative two-thirds to negative 5/6
negative two-thirds to negative 5/6 well
what is that going to be so let's see if
I do negative negative 2/3 is the same
thing as negative 4 6 minus 5/6 which is
equal to negative 9 6 which is equal to
negative 3 halves so this right over
here is the same thing as negative 3
halves let me just write that negative 3
halves power negative 2/3 plus negative
5/6 is negative 3 halves now what's
interesting is I have a negative
three-halves up here and I have a
negative three-halves over here so we
can do the same thing we did in the last
problem
this could simplify to 12 w 12 w to the
seventh power over 3 w squared 3 w
squared all of that all of that to the
all of that to the negative 3 half power
notice what we did here had something to
the negative 3 halves divided by
something else to that negative
three-halves well that's the same thing
as doing the division first and then
raising that that the quotient to the
negative three-halves and what's nice
about this this is pretty
straightforward to simplify 12 divided
by 3 is 4 and W to the 7th divided by W
squared well we can divide both by W
squared or you could say this is the
same thing as W to the 7 minus 2 power
so this is going to be W to the 5th
power W to the fifth power
and so it all simplified to four W to
the fifth power to the negative
three-halves to the negative
three-halves now if we want to this is
already pretty simple and at some point
it becomes somewhat opinion someone's
opinion on which expression is simpler
than another and it might depend on what
you're using the expression for but one
could argue that you could keep trying
to simplify this this is the same thing
as this is the same thing as four to the
negative three-halves to the negative
three-halves x times W to the fifth to
the negative three-halves and once again
this is just straight out of our
exponent properties now 4 to the
negative three-halves let's just think
about that four to the negative
three-halves
just in a different color just as a bit
of an aside so 4 to the negative
three-halves is equal to that's the same
thing as 1 over 4 to the three-halves
and that's C 4 to the the square root of
4 is 2 and we raise that to the third
power it's going to be 8 so this is
equal to 1/8 so that's equal to 1/8 and
so all this is going to be equal to 1/8
and then W to the fifth and then that to
the negative three-halves we can
multiply these exponents that's going to
be w to the 5 times negative
three-halves what's going to be the
negative 15 halves power so I don't know
which one you would say is simpler this
one over here or this one over here but
they are equivalent and they both are a
lot simpler than where we started